Greetings to my 3BN family and welcome
to another 3BN today Bible Q&A. We've
got another hourpacked program with your
Bible questions and we've got the
answers right here in the word of God.
I'm Ricky Carter. I'm going to be your
host today and let me introduce you to
our panelists who will be answering
these questions. To my right is Sister
Shelley Quinn. Welcome, sister.
>> Oh, it's always a joy to be here. Thank
you so much for sending your questions
because we enjoy getting into the Bible,
looking up the answers and sharing that
with you.
>> Amen. Amen. And next to her is my
brother, Pastor John Denzy. Welcome,
sir.
>> Thank you. It's a blessing to be here
and love studying God's word and
depending on the Lord for answers.
>> Amen. Amen. And next to him, we have my
another brother, Pastor James Rafferty.
Welcome, sir.
>> Amen. Good to be here. I'm here in the
spirit. It says as it says in 1
Corinthians 5, one of the ch u chapters
we'll be looking at. It's such a
privilege uh to be part of the team.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, before we go into our
start our program, we always want to
start off with a word of prayer so we
can get God to help us understand what
his word says. Pastor Denzy, could you
lead us in prayer?
>> Yes. Let's go to the Lord in prayer. Our
loving heavenly father,
thank you so much Lord for giving us the
scriptures to light our pathway and to
know that you love us and to know that
[music] you have a plan to rescue us
from this world of suffering.
>> Thank you that [music] we can see
evidence that Jesus Christ is coming
soon. And Lord, in this program we ask
for the blessing of your Holy Spirit.
[music] We pray that you will give us
the answers from your word.
>> Yes.
>> And guide us as we study. We ask in
Jesus name. Amen. Amen. Amen.
Well, before I pass out the first
question, let me share with you how you
can participate with this program. You
can do it one of three ways. First, you
can email us your questions to
bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
Or you can text us to 618-2283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions that way at 3abn_official.
At 3BN official. All right, Sister
Shelley, here's your first question.
Everything I've learned tells me that
God abhors human sacrifice. First and
foremost, it directly violates the
commandment, "Thou shalt not kill."
Even more, it contradicts his
instructions regarding acceptable
sacrifices for the atonement of sin.
Yet, Judges 11:es 30- 40 recounts a
story of what appears to be a human
sacrifice that God accepts. How can this
be?
What was its purpose? And is there a
lesson for us in this account? And
that's from MGA in Delaware who texted
that question to us. Well, I think
there's some really good lessons in this
account. First, let me say that Judges
11 does not show that God approves of
human sacrifice. God's stance, he he
thought of human sacrifice as an
abomination. And he clearly hated it. He
repeatedly I looked up I had a list of
maybe 14 scriptures where God is telling
them don't do this. Let me give you an
example. He condemned human sacrifice.
And we'll look at Deuteronomy 12:31. You
shall not worship the Lord your God in
that way. He's talking about this pagan
manner. He said, um, he called it an
abomination to the Lord, which he hates
because the pagans offered their
children to their pagan gods.
>> Now, even though God forbade this
atrocity, some of Israel practiced
[clears throat] it. And we see that this
was not only something God hated, but he
said in Jeremiah 7:31,
"It was that which I did not command,
nor did it come into my heart." He never
even thought about this. The God of love
would never allow that. What God
commanded was animal sacrifices because
they were symbols pointing to the coming
Messiah, Jesus Christ, the true lamb of
God. So human sacrifice was never ever
his intention. And the Jeepa story in
Judges 11 must be read with this
viewpoint. Now though Jeepa was chosen
by God to deliver Israel in battle,
he lived in a spiritually dark era. A
time when some of the pagan practices
mixed with Israel's faith. They these
heathen ideas had an influence. So
rather than trusting God's simple
promise for victory in battle, what
Jeffa did was made a rash vow. I mean
this was ill advised. It was
>> stupidity on his part, but it revealed
the lingering influence of heathen
ideas. Let's look at that vow. Judges
11:30
through31. He's saying, "God, if you
give me victory over the Ammonites,
I will offer whatever, this is the
quote, whatever comes out of my house
will be the Lord's, and I will offer it
up as a burnt offering." Now, this
reflected a very serious misjudgment. I
mean, Jeepa didn't understand God's
character at all. And verse 34,
when he has the victory and returns
home, guess what? It was his daughter,
his only child, that was first out of
the door.
>> Now he's in shock, but he explains the
vow to the daughter. Listen to the
daughter's response. She asks for two
months to bewail her virginity. That
means to mourn her virginity. If in my
mind if she thought if I thought
somebody was getting ready to sacrifice
me, I wouldn't be worried whether I was
a virgin or not. Right? That's what I'm
just going to say. So there's two
interpretations that arise. There is
some that believe it's a literal
sacrifice that he tragically carried out
a human sacrifice
but that would be a grave sin that was
not divinely sanctioned.
>> Then there are some who believe many
seventh day all seventh day Adventist
scholars believe a dedication view that
his daughter was consecrated to lifelong
virginity. That's why she asks, you
know, she'd be the service at the
temple, at the tabernacle in lifelong
virginity and that she was not killed.
But and and there's something about the
repeated focus on her virginity in
Judges 11:37 through39 that supports
this. I tend to believe that second
view.
>> The daughter's faith though, whether
death or lifelong service, teaches us
the same lessons. Let me give you three
real quick and we'll if we got time at
the end of the program, I'll expand
them. Guard your words. Don't make rash
promises. God seeks obedience, not
bargaining. Avoid cultural compromise
and understand Christ is our true
sacrifice.
>> Amen. Thank you, sister. Uh I learned
something myself there.
>> Good.
>> All right, Pastor Denzy, here's your
first question.
When Jesus was on earth, he had his
disciples. He and his he had his
disciples and John the Baptist also had
his own followers. After Jesus
ascension, many who had been baptized by
John chose to be rebapti rebaptized
under Jesus baptism. Based on this, why
do 7th Day Adventist churches accept
members from other denominations without
requiring rebaptism? That's from Kay in
Virginia who texted that to us.
>> Thank you very much, Kay. I I would like
to go to Acts chapter 19 and begin in
verse one to to get a context of what
was happening and why these disciples
were rebaptized. And it says uh here and
it happened while Apollos was at Corenth
that Paul having passed through the
upper regions came to Ephesus and
finding some disciples he said to them
did you receive the Holy Spirit when you
believed? So they said, "We have not so
much as heard whether there is a Holy
Spirit." And he said to them, "Into
which into what then were you baptized?"
So they said, "Into John's baptism."
Then Paul said, "John indeed baptized
with a baptism of repentance, saying to
the people that they should believe on
him who would come after him, that is on
Christ Jesus." So they did not know
Christ Jesus. So this is why they were
baptized in Jesus' name. Notice what it
says. When they heard this, they were
baptized in the name of the Lord Jesus.
>> So there is a difference between John's
baptism
and then being baptized knowing that
Jesus Christ is the Messiah is the
savior.
>> This is why rebaptism was necessary.
Notice in John 14:6, you will know this
verse. Jesus said to him, "I am the way,
the truth, and the life. No one comes to
the father except through me. These
disciples did not know that. So they had
to be re rebaptized because Jesus uh
would be their savior. They would
understand that Jesus is the Messiah. He
is my savior. So the seventh day
adventist church presents to people that
need to be rebaptized when they have not
been baptized according to the biblical
way.
And there are some denominations that do
not baptize according to the biblical
way. They sprinkle people. But the very
word baptism which [clears throat] is
baptisma or baptiso
means to be submerged to be immersed in
water completely underwater.
So when these people they come from
other denominations where they have been
sprinkled, they need to be baptized
according to the biblical way.
>> And so this is why the 7th day Adventist
church uh tells these individuals to be
rebaptized because they have not been
baptized according to the biblical way.
Take a look at Romans chapter 6, which
helps us understand that we are baptized
by being submerged into the water and
brought back out. meaning a a
resurrection to newness of life. So what
about the people that are from other
denominations that have been baptized
according to the biblical way? That is
they were uh submerged underwater and
then brought back out. The Seventh Day
Adventist Church does not see a need for
these people to be rebaptized because
they believed in Jesus Christ as their
personal savior and they were baptized
according to the biblical way.
>> So, so this is why the seventh day
Adventist Church takes the stand that
these individuals that come into the
seventh day Adventist church from mother
denominations baptized according to the
biblical way can come into the church
and become members by profession of
faith. That means they now understand
new doctrines, new truths from the
Bible. They accept these and now they
come in uh as professional faith. Now,
it's left up to the individual because
some people say, "No, no, I want to be
rebaptized." And that's up to the
individual. So, this is not something
that the the church forces them or or
tells them you have to get rebaptized
because uh you you're coming into the
church. know they already were baptized
according to the biblical way and they
know that Jesus Christ is their personal
savior and they cannot save themselves.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you for that answer,
sir. Okay, Pastor James, here's your
first question. Can you please explain 1
Corinthians chapter 5?
>> Short question gives me plenty of time
to answer. Now the context of 1
Corinthians chapter 5 uh is a church
that the apostle Paul has planted but
that is backsliding and there are many
areas where these new believers are
failing to live up to the grace of God
in their lives and this chapter is one
of them. Let's just read a few verses
here. 1 Corinthians 5:es 1-5. It is
reported commonly that there is
fornication among you, and such
fornication as is not so much as named
among the Gentiles, that one should have
his father's wife, and you are puffed
up, and you have not rather mourned that
ye have uh that he that hath done this
deed might be taken away from among you,
that is dysfellowship. For verily, I I
am absent in the body, but present in
the spirit, and I'm judged already as
though I were present concerning him
that has done this deed. So in the name
of the Lord Jesus Christ, when we are
gathered together in my spirit uh and
and the in the power of the Lord Jesus
Christ, we need to deliver such an one
unto Satan for the destruction of the
flesh that the spirit might be saved in
the day of the Lord Jesus Christ. Now
those are some strong words, but Paul is
simply talking here about church
discipline. And notice what he says here
at the very end. He says, "The reason
we're doing this is so that person can
be saved in the name of the Lord Jesus
Christ." In other words, we're not dis
uh dysfellowshipping him and
disciplining him so he can be lost.
We're disciplining him so he can be
saved, so he can be awakened. And he
also uses the phrase there. He he says,
"We're going to hand him over to Satan."
Well, in Ephesians 2 2 and 3, that's
exactly where Paul says we came from. We
were walking according to the prince of
the power of the air, according to the
prince of this world. And Satan's bas
Paul is basically saying if we
dysfellowship him we're we'll hand him
back over to where he came from when he
was in the world. But hopefully it will
wake him up. 1 Corinthians 5:6
through13. Your glory is not good. Know
you not that a little leven the whole
lump. In other words, if you allow
people to stay in the church that are
sinning, it's going to leave in the
whole church. Everyone's going to think
it's okay to do their little sin or
their little sin over here because
you're not dealing with this sin. Purge
out therefore the old leven that you may
be a new lump as you are unleven for
even Christ our Passover is sacrificed
for us. Therefore let us keep the feast
not with the old leven ne with the leven
of malice or wickedness but with the
unleven bread of sincerity and truth.
Right? Don't allow hypocrisy to be in
the church. And then he goes on to say I
wrote unto you in an epistle. And here's
the the key point here and this is going
to parallel Matthew 18 15 to 18 in
gospel order. I wrote unto you in an
epistle, not to company with
fornicators, yet not altogether with the
fornicators of this world, or with the
covetous or extortioners, or with the
idolattors. For then you must need needs
to go out of the world. In Matthew 18,
Jesus says, when someone's
dysfellowshipped
because they're not repentant of their
open sin, we should treat them as a
sinner and a publican. And Jesus Christ,
how did he treat sinners and publicans?
He sat with them. He ate with them. He
even defended them. John chapter 8, he
defended the woman that was caught in
the very act of adultery. And so we see
Jesus Christ giving his example in
Matthew 9:10. He sat with si with
publicans and sinners. What we're what
Paul is doing is the very same thing
here. He's saying, listen, I don't want
you to be separating yourself from all
these people in the world. But I'm what
he's saying what he goes on to say is
but if they're in the church if they're
in the church. But now I've written unto
you not to keep company if a man that is
called a brother be a fornicator or a
covetous or an adulterer or a or
a drunkard or an extortioner with such
and one not to eat. No. So what Paul is
dealing with here is church discipline.
And it's powerful. Paul is instructing
them to dysfellowship members who are in
open sin which means handing them back
over to the rule of this world. But not
because he wants them to be lost, it's
because he wants them to be saved. The
Bible says in Hebrews chapter 12 and in
Ro uh Revelation chapter 3, as many as
God loves, he rebukes and chasens. It's
it's a disservice to people not to
discipline them if they're members of
the church because they're living in
open sin. It's a it's a manifestation of
a lack of love that we fail to do that
because we're more concerned about our
how we're going to be seen by them and
we're going to be mean or etc. rather
than their eternal salvation. And by the
way, when Paul writes his second letter
to the Corinthians, this brother has
been redeemed and he encourages them to
forgive him. And you you read that in 2
Corinthians chapter 2:es 4-11. It
worked. Uh forgive him, comfort him.
Don't let him be overwhelmed with
excessive sorrow. Bring him back into
the church. And of course, we see this.
It's so beautiful to see this balance in
the way Paul deals with sin in Corinth.
And of course, it's in harmony with the
way Jesus tells us to deal with sin in
the church in Matthew 18:15 to18. I hope
that's helpful.
>> Amen. Thank you. That was very, very
helpful. Thank you, sir.
>> All right, Sister Shelley,
>> here's your second question. Is it
proper to baptize six-year-old children?
And that was sent to us via text
message.
>> I'm glad that that came up next since
you just got on baptism. Christian
baptism is not a ritual.
It's it is really in the New Testament
we see it as a conscious decision based
on personal faith in Jesus Christ as
Lord. A lot of the people you were
talking about that were sprinkled
whereas sprinkled as children. It's not
baptism. You have to understand the
power of Christ's sacrificial death. You
have to understand your personal state.
of your your sinful nature and you have
to be able to repent ex and express a
desire of lifelong commitment to follow
Jesus Christ and to obey motivated by
love to following the Holy Spirit. So
readiness is measured by understanding
not by age. Baptism is for those who are
old enough to understand the meaning of
conversion
>> and dying to self and being raised in
newness of life as a witness to the
world that you are uniting your life
with Jesus Christ. I'll again read
Romans 6 verse 3 and 4. Paul says, "Do
you not know that as many as you were
baptized in to Christ Jesus were
baptized into Christ, not into a
church?"
>> So, you're baptized into Christ Jesus
were baptized into his death. Therefore,
we were buried with him, buried with him
through baptism under the water into
death. That just as Christ was raised
from the dead by the glory of the
father, even so we should also walk in
newness of life. So, while there's no
specific age that's set, it's not
usually appropriate to baptize a
six-year-old child because they're
typically too young to grasp the meaning
of baptiz baptism and the lifelong
commitment that they are making. They've
not yet developed that understanding of
commitment. Now, there could be
exceptions if some child, a
six-year-old, has an incredibly unusual
maturity in spiritual matters. But what
I would do with if I had a six-year-old
child that was interested, I would
nurture that interest. I would teach
them and encourage them until they were
old enough to make typically we think of
10 to 12 years old when people are
really beginning to understand. And
we're we are cautioned in evangelism
page 594
not to baptize children too early and
not to rush them.
>> Very good. Thank you, sister.
>> All right, Pastor Denzy, here's your
second question.
Why was God going to kill Moses in
Exodus 4:es 24- 26? That was sent to us
from Shannon in Massachusetts who texted
that to us.
>> [snorts]
>> Thank you Shannon. A very good question.
And so let's go to Exodus chapter 4 and
verses 24- 26 and let's think about
these things. And it says, "And it came
to pass on the way at the encampment
that the Lord met him and sought to kill
him." Then Zapora took a sharp stone and
cut off the foreskin of her son and cast
it at Moses' feet and said, "Surely you
are a husband of blood to me." Let's
stop right here for a moment uh and
consider remember Numbers 22 that the
prophet was [snorts] on his way on a
donkey and the donkey saw an angel with
a drawn sword
>> and it seemed as if he was heading right
that way and the donkey tried to
actually moved and bumped his his leg
and of course uh Bam got upset about
this. Notice the wording here because it
says that the Lord met him. It appeared
to Moses and appeared to Zapora in the
same situation that it appeared like
Moses' life is in danger. Now in
reality, if you think about it, if this
was really the intent, this was a d this
was a message, you are in danger. This
is what it was. You are in danger. Why?
Because Moses was not fulfilling what
God has said. How do we know that?
Because of what Zippora did. And also
consider the timing. If the Lord really
wants to, as is as you you say, kill
somebody, that would be an instant
thing. But there appears to be time
enough for Zippora to evaluate the
situation and say, "Uhoh, it's because
we have not completed the circumcision
of her son." And so she sees,
understands, goes to get a knife. time
passes, grabs her son, gets him ready
for this surgical procedure and all of
this takes place in that time. So this
was uh a a message of warning and so
Zapora understood it and so it says in
verse 26, so he so he let him go. So who
who let go who? So it must be uh the
angel of the Lord or or the warning was
removed. Then she said, "You are a
husband of blood because of the
circumcision." So the issue of the
circumcision is the main uh issue here.
And Moses was about to embark on a a
mission from God as a representative of
God. And if he's not fulfilling the
requirements of God, which included
circumcision, which was a covenant uh an
emblem of the covenant that God had with
the people of Israel, how can he be a
leader of the people if he's failing in
this part of the requirements of God? So
that's the reason and that's what's
going on in here based on the context
that we see.
>> Amen. Thank you for that answer. Yes,
sir. Good one. All right, Pastor James,
here's your second question. If in
heaven there will be no more families,
why do we comfort those who have lost a
loved one by saying they will be re
reunited with their spouse, children, or
parents? Will the family unit truly be
restored? That's from Maurice who
emailed that to us.
>> Great question, Maurice. I was really
started thinking about this when you
asked that question and some thoughts
came to my mind. You know, the Bible
does not actually teach that there will
be no more families in heaven. At least
not that I know of. The Bible says that
there will be no more marrying or giving
in marriage. Let's take a look in
Matthew 22:30.
It says there, "For in the resurrection,
they neither marry nor are given in
marriage, but are as the angels of God
in heaven." So there's not really a
reason why the family unit would not be
intact and families restored as part of
the great family of God after the
resurrection. I think that babies will
be reunited with their mothers and I
think that the family unit will be
connected in some way, but there's not
going to be a marrying and giving in
marriage. There's not going to be this
new development of families. The ending
of new family relationships doesn't
really prohibit the exclusion of family
relationships that have already been
formed among believers um on earth prior
to the second coming. You know, when we
read the Bible, we want to do what's
called ex Jesus, right? That means
taking out of the text what is in the
text. And the word exes Jesus literally
means to lead out. And when we lead out
of a text, we are doing exes Jesus. Now
the opposite of ex Jesus is isog Jesus
which literally means to lead into. Is
Jesus is when we put something in the
text that's not necessarily there. So
when we read Matthew 22:30
again it says for in the resurrection
they neither marry nor are given in
marriage but as the angels of God in
heaven. So ex Jesus would conclude that
after the resurrection there's not
marrying nor giving in marriage. That's
all that would conclude from this verse.
is Jesus might conclude that after the
resurrection there's no more family
units because um you know there's not
going to be any more marriages after the
resurrection. Now the isog Jesus is
putting something into the text that's
not actually there. So again the Bible
doesn't actually teach as far as I know
that families will not be reunited in
heaven. Uh it teaches that there'll be
no more new marriages happening after
the resurrection. But the family is the
family, right? God's family, the 3ABN
family, your family, believers and
families, even relationships that are
beyond families. I think they're going
to be rekindled, reconnecting in heaven.
We have every reason to believe that all
families will be reunited in heaven.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, sir. All right.
Michelle, I've got your third question,
but before I give that to you, let me
remind our viewers at home how you can
participate with 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
You can do so one of three ways. You can
email us your questions to
bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
Or you can text us your questions to
618-228-3975.
That's 618-228-3975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions at 3abn_official
at 3abn_official.
All right, Shelley. Number three, third
question. Can you explain the difference
between the gift of prophecy and the
spirit of prophecy? That's from Frank in
California who texted that to us.
>> Frank, I love this question. We're going
to begin with the gift of prophecy. The
gift of prophecy is one of the spiritual
gifts that is given by the Holy Spirit
to individuals for building up the
church. We see in first Corinians
12:es 7- 11 a list of spiritual gifts
that the Holy Spirit gives as he decides
to every member gets a gift. Prophecy is
among this. Not every member prophesies,
but that's among this. And this is part
of Christ's plan to equip the church.
The gift of prophecy, we're staying on
the gift, is the spirit inspired ability
to speak for God.
>> It isn't just fortelling
something, an event, but it's providing
counsel, encouragement, and guidance for
his people. The gift of prophecy, still
focusing on the gift, is an individual
manifestation of prophecy in a chosen
person. We see this in both the Old and
the New Testament. And we see seventh
day Adventists believe in the ministry
of Ellen White. Now, let's go from the
gift to the spirit of prophecy. The
spirit of prophecy is the divine source
of the gift.
>> The spirit of prophecy refers to the
Holy Spirit's agency in inspiring
prophetic messages. First second Peter
Second Peter 1:21,
the holy men of God spoke as they were
moved by the Holy Ghost. Revelation
19:10, the testimony of Jesus is the
spirit of prophecy. So in other words,
prophecy is Jesus speaking to his people
through the Holy Spirit. So the spirit
of prophecy, staying on the second one,
is the power behind the gift, the Holy
Spirit who gives the gift. Revelation
12:17
identifies the remnant church as keeping
the commandments of God and having the
testimony of Jesus,
>> which we know Revelation 19:10
says is the spirit of prophecy.
So to kind of sum up spirit of prophecy,
it refers broadly to Christ's testimony
through his prophets. Ellen White's
writings in the Seventh Day Adventist
Church are called the spirit of prophecy
because they are the modern
manifestation of the biblical gift given
to point us back to scripture and
prepare a people for Christ's soon
return.
She herself explained it in selected
messages book three page 29. My writings
will not give new light but will impress
vividly upon the heart the truth of
inspiration already revealed. So her
writings referred to as the spirit of
prophecy was a manifestation of the gift
of prophecy and they are divinely
inspired to direct us back to the Bible.
Her work never replaces scripture points
us back to it. So summary gift of
prophecy over here is the spiritual gift
given to individuals to speak for God.
The spirit of prophecy is the Holy
Spirit's ongoing testimony of Jesus
Christ.
>> Amen. Thank you, sister. Real well put
there. All right, Pastor Denzy, here's
your third question.
Why didn't Lot go back to Abraham when
he fled from Sodom? He asked the angels
to let him go to Zor, after which he
went to the mountains. His daughters
then decided they wanted kids. Would
they not have found husbands among
Abraham's servants? That's from Edna in
the UK who emailed that to us.
>> Thank you, Edna. I am with you. Why?
Why? You know, you look at some of these
things in the Bible and you say, "Why
didn't they do this instead of that?"
And so that happens in our lives as as
well because sometimes after we do
whatever it is that we've done that
sometime later as the Holy Spirit moves
upon our hearts and we understand what a
mistake that was, we like why did I do
that? Mhm.
>> So we have this situation here which is
uh troubling, very troubling because uh
Lot was with Abraham for a long time and
saw the wonderful righteous example that
Abraham presented before him. H now not
everyone is familiar with the story. So
I'm going to go to Genesis chapter 19
and read some verses uh there to help uh
us uh get in the context of what's going
on. [snorts] It's uh just like you said,
they were up in that mountain. It says,
"Now the firstborn said to the younger,
our father is old and there is no man on
earth on the earth to come into us as is
the custom of all the earth." Great
mistake. Like you said, there were
others and Abraham uh they could have
joined them. They had families, but
somehow they're confused. Somehow they
don't understand. Somehow they have been
corrupted because now she says come let
us make our father drink wine. What what
are they doing? They know he would not
agree to this of course. So this is why
they resort to something that the devil
would suggest. Uh so and we will lie
with him that we may preserve the
lineage of our father. Seems like a uh a
a worthy uh thing to do. However, we
never accomplish good things by doing
wrong things. We don't arrive at good at
good results. So, they made their father
drink wine. They were both in cahoots,
as some people say, that night. And the
firstborn went in and lay with her
father. And he did not know when she
laid down or when she arose. Don't ask
me why, but this is what happened. So,
the next night,
uh, the firstborn tells the younger
daughter, "Hey, now it's your turn." And
of course the same thing happens. They
make him drunk and he's drunk. Doesn't
know when they she lies with him and
when she gets up. What are the results?
The results are horrible.
It says in uh verse uh 36 of Genesis 39,
thus both the daughters of Lot were with
child by their father. The firstborn
bore a son and called his name Moab.
He's the father of the Moabites to this
day. And the younger, she also bore a
son and called his name Ben Ami. He is
the father of all the people of Ammon to
this day. As you read the scriptures,
you will see that both of these
tribes of people were consistently idol
worshippers and troublemakers.
>> So this is the result of evil. I'm going
to point to you to a principle in 1
Corinthians 15:33. Be not deceived. Evil
communications corrupt good manners.
evil associations, the things we we
expose oursel to can corrupt good
manners. And this is what happened to
them while they were in Sodom and
Gomorrah. And so uh the results are seen
and we see bad bad results and it was a
a terrible terrible thing. There's more
to share but other questions. [laughter]
>> Thank you. Thank you very much, sir. All
right, Pastor James, here's your third
question. Can you explain 1st Samuel
chapter 19:9?
Does God have an evil spirit? That's
from Jack who emailed that to us.
>> Thank you, Jack, for that question.
That's a really good question and it's
an important one when we look at the big
story in the Bible, uh, the overview of
the Bible because God does not have an
evil spirit, but God is often seen doing
what he allows. Now, the verse you're
talking about is in 1st Samuel chapter
19:9. And an evil spirit from the Lord
was upon Saul as he sat in the house
with his javelin in his hand, and David
played with his hand. Now, what's
interesting about the story is is that
David is God's anointed, and David is
actually protected by the Lord. So, we
know that God wasn't sending a spirit to
Saul to kill David because we know that
God was actually protecting David. When
it says an evil spirit, it's talking
about Saul's choices. We could read the
verse an evil spirit was upon Saul. When
it says from the Lord, that phrase right
there actually is just mentioning the
Lord. It's talking about what the Lord
allows. And we see this all through the
Bible. For example, in the story of Job,
Job chapter 2:es 1-3. Let's just read
those verses again. There was a day when
the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord. And Satan
came also among them to present himself
before the Lord. And the Lord said unto
Satan, "From whence comest thou?" And
Satan answered the Lord and said, "From
going to and fro in the earth, and from
walking up and down in it." And the Lord
said unto Satan, "Hast thou considered
my servant Job? There is none like him
in the earth, a perfect and an upright
man, and one that fears God and assues
evil. And still he holds fast his
integrity. although you move me against
him to destroy him without cause. Well,
God didn't do anything against Job
except allow Satan to step in. So, we
know from reading the first chapter of
Job that it was the devil, not God, that
was moved against Job to destroy him. I
mean, we read this in, for example,
verse 12 of chapter 1. The Lord said
unto Satan, "Behold, all that he has is
in your power, only upon himself. Put
forth not your hands." So, Satan goes
forth from the presence of the Lord and
brings all kinds of evil upon Job. God
is seen as doing at times what he allows
because God is sovereign. So, God in the
story of Job and many other stories is
seen as giving people over to the
choices that they have made like Saul
and we see this in the New Testament. We
talked about it in Romans 1:es 21-28
uh in an earlier Q&A and we also talked
about it in an earlier question here
where Paul says hand this this member of
the church that's sinning like the world
or even worse than the world hand him
over to the devil in other words
dysfellowship him right so this person
is choosing the devil and we the church
is simply following through with their
choice they're making the choice but it
looks like the church is the one that's
doing it when really they're simply
honoring the choice of the person. Many
times that's what we see with God. God
allows people to reap the consequences
of what they've chosen rather than
actually doing it. He gives them over to
that. Well, that sounds like he's doing
it. In Romans chapter 1 24 20- 28, it
says that God hands them over or God
gives them over. Sounds like he's
active. Well, he's not. He's simply
honoring their free choice. And that's
what we see here in the story of Saul.
Saul has chosen to turn away from God.
He won't won't follow his prophet. He
won't follow his word. He is not
listening to God's voice. And so God
steps back and an evil spirit comes in.
Hope that's helpful.
>> Very helpful. Thank you, sir.
>> Amen.
>> All right, Sister Shelley, here's your
last question.
>> How can you tell if a vision or a
message is from God or Satan? That's
from a viewer in Virginia who texted
that to us. Well, I'm going to start off
by saying your your greatest safeguard
is to stay anchored in the word and
anchored in prayer. You discern God's
voice from Satan's by testing everything
against the Bible, observing the fruits
and leaning on the spirit's guidance.
Let's look at that. Number one, test
everything by the word of God. Any
vision, impression, or message that you
feel you're receiving from the Lord, if
you [clears throat] receive it from the
Lord, it will always agree with
scripture. The Holy Spirit isn't going
to contradict scripture. Isaiah 8:20
says, "To the law and to the testimony,
if they do not speak according to these,
it is because there is no light in
them." You know, Satan can give
counterfeit
visions, but he can't align them with
the full truth of God. Number two, look
at the fruits. Jesus said in Matthew
7:16,
"By their fruits, you will know them." A
true message from God will draw you
closer to Jesus Christ. It will produce
humility,
obedience, love, peace, and uplift God's
character. Now, Satan's counterfeits,
you see it happen. It can lead to pride
and feeling puffed up or confusion or
fear
>> or disobedience.
>> So, look at the fruit. Number three,
depend on the Holy Spirit's discernment.
Jesus promised in John 16:13,
the spirit of truth will guide us into
all truth. Now, the beauty of that is
when we are praying for the spirit's
guidance, we're fasting and then we seek
counsel from other mature Christians.
This helps us discern. The Holy Spirit
will lead us into unity and truth. And
as I said, never will he contradict
God's word.
>> So remember this. Satan seeks to do just
the opposite. He wants to divide. He
wants to deceive.
And you know what? Sometimes his
counterfeits may make you feel powerful,
but never go by feelings. Only go by the
word feelings can lead you to rebellion.
So here's what I would say. Ask
yourself, does this message agree with
the Bible?
Does it exalt Christ and his
righteousness?
Does it lead me to obedience, service,
and service or to self-exaltation
and fear? And do godly counselors affirm
it is from God? God's messages will
always uplift Christ, align with
scripture, and bring you into obedience
and peace.
>> Very good. Thank you, sister. Amen.
>> All right, Pastor Dy, here's your final
question.
>> Were all animals created from the dust
like humans? That's from Yah in Ghana
who emailed that to us.
>> Wow, thank you so much. I I'm I'm amazed
as I hear the different countries where
>> 3ABN is reaching. Praise the Lord for
that.
>> Well, thank you for the question and uh
the answer, the short one is almost
[laughter]
in Genesis 1 24 like you said. Uh and it
says, "And God said, let the earth bring
forth the living creatures after his
kind, cattle and creeping things and
beasts of the earth after his kind. And
it was so." Genesis 1:24. Now we also
know that God created uh Adam and Eve
from the dust of the ground. But in
Genesis chapter 1 verse 20 and 21 there
is another element used. Let's go there.
Then God God said let the waters abound
with an abundance of living creatures
and let birds fly above the earth across
the face of the firmament of the
heavens. So God created great sea
creatures and every living thing that
moves with which the waters abounded
according to their kind and every winged
bird according to his kind and God saw
that it was good. Now [snorts] some
people come to the conclusion upon uh
reading Genesis 1 20 and 21 that God
created the birds from the waters but
that is not so uh God created the birds
from the ground. Let's go to Genesis
chapter 2 verse uh 19. It says, "Out of
the ground, the Lord God formed every
beast of the field and every bird of the
air and brought them to Adam to see what
he would call them." And whatever Adam
called earth, whatever Adam called each
living creature, that that was its name.
So, so we see here evidence that God
used uh dirt and God also used the
waters to create uh the creatures upon
the earth. So, it's not just dust, it's
also water that was used. And so, praise
the Lord. Uh he can create something out
of nothing. So, we praise the Lord. I
mean, when he says, "Let there be light
and there was light." It shows God is
almighty and can do great and mighty
things that is beyond our understanding.
You know, I also marvel that uh as I
have had the opportunity to look into
microscopes, the detail even in those
things that our eyes cannot see.
>> It's uh it's a marvel of God's creation
and his power and his ability to be an
artist in the creation process. I would
say that way.
>> Amen. Thank you, sir. Yes. God is a
wonderful artist. Yes. All right. Pastor
James got your last question.
Revelation
12:5 describes a woman giving birth to a
male child while the dragon waits to
destroy him. I understand that the male
child represents Jesus Christ and the
dragon represents Satan. I always
thought the woman symbolized Israel, but
I recently learned that my church
teaches the woman represents the church.
How can the church give birth to Christ
when it was Christ who gave birth to the
church? That's from Sally in Oregon who
texted that to us.
>> That's a great question, Sally. Thank
you so much. You know, you are 100%
correct. The woman in Revelation 12:es
1-5 represents Israel, God's Old
Testament church. Now, we know a woman
in the Bible is symbolic of a church. A
virtuous woman represents God's church
as noted in Revelation 12:1 and other
scriptures like 2 Corinthians 11 2 and
3. But also a harlot woman can represent
an unfaithful church as noted in
Revelation chapter 17 1-6. And you can
read about that in Isaiah 11 or excuse
me, Isaiah 1. Uh I think it's 11, but
Isaiah chapter 1. You read the whole
chapter, you'll find it there. How's the
faithful city become a harlot? Might be
verse 17. So there are several reasons
though why we know that the woman in
Revelation 12 1-5 represents God's Old
Testament church. Now again, we're using
that church interchangeably. Old
Testament church, Israel, New Testament
church, Christian church, but still the
church. Now, as you mentioned, Jesus is
born of the woman. And since Jesus was
born of the Jewish Hebrew church, this
woman would represent Israel. All right,
the Old Testament church. Number two,
probation for Israel as a nation did not
close until after Jesus died on the
cross. You know, according to the Bible
prophecy of the 70 weeks, AD.34,
the end point of the 70we prophecy
occurred when Steven was stoned. And of
course, then the gospel went to the
Gentiles officially. Now, that doesn't
mean that Jewish people are no longer
under God's grace. The whole world is
under an envelope of God's grace. But
God does not have them as the sole
denominated people of the gospel of
Jesus Christ. Anyone who accepts Christ,
whether Jew or Gentile, is now a
Christian and part of God's New
Testament church. The dragon, we are
told in these verses, stands before the
woman to destroy Jesus as soon as he's
born. Now, the dragon is the devil
according to Revelation 12:9. And the
devil works through earthly powers. And
in this case, he worked through King
Herod to try to kill Christ shortly
after his birth. So that would line up
those verses in Revelation 12 would line
up with Matthew 2 16 to 21. And finally,
we see that the transition from literal
Israel to spiritual Israel or the
Christian church actually takes place in
verse 6 of Revelation 12 when the woman
flees into the wilderness for what we
understand to be 1260 years. In summary
then, the woman in Revelation 12
represents both the Old Testament Jewish
church and the new New Testament
Christian church. In verses 1-5, the
woman gives birth to Jesus. So this is
the Jewish church. And then beginning in
verse six, the woman flees into the
wilderness to escape persecution during
the 1260 prophetic days or literal
years. So that then would be the
Christian church. I hope this uh this
answer is helpful for you.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, thank you all for all
your answers from the word and I hope
that you all were blessed by that. I
know I was. You know, it's always a
blessing to study God's word and and see
where we can find all those answers.
Before we take a break, I want to remind
you we've got a wonderful website. Not
sure if you've checked it out, but it's
called 3ABNBibleansers.com.
If you check that website out where you
can get a lot of your Bible questions
answered on a wide variety of topics,
topics like the mark of the beast.
There's a question, there's some
questions there. What is the mark of the
beast? Is it a monster computer system
hidden away somewhere in Europe or is it
a microscopic chip to be embedded under
the skin? More questions are there uh on
that site and the answers are there as
well. We're going to take a short break
to let you know how you can participate
with this program. We'll be right back.
If you're enjoying our 3BN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word [music] to shed
light on those texts that seem difficult
to understand. To have your questions
[music] answered on a future program,
just email them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
TV. That's bible QA3abn.tv.
You may [music] also text your questions
to 618-2283975.
That's 618-2283975.
Be sure to include your name and [music]
where you live and then watch through
Bible Q&A for answers from God's word.
Well, our time is almost up, but before
we go, let's get some final thoughts
from our panelists. Sister Shelley,
>> I'm just thinking about Judges 11 and
the story of Jeepa. To me, the greatest
takeaway is guard your mouth. In
Ecclesiastes 5:2, it warns against rash
vows. We need to trust God's promises,
measure our words, and walk in
obedience.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. I'm thinking about Lot's
daughters and you know they were exposed
to things that blurred their perception
of what is right and what is wrong.
>> And so I want to encourage you to
examine the things you see, hear and
associate with because your perception
of what is right and wrong can become
blurred and that which was which is evil
you may come to accept as right. So, uh,
I encourage you to keep your eyes on
Jesus and examine yourself so that you
know you're walking with the Lord.
>> Amen, Pastor James.
>> And just, yeah, just building on that
thought, you going back to 1 Corinthians
chapter 5, Paul points out that the
church is puffed up. Very similar to the
condition of the Leadyian church in
Revelation 3 that refuses to rebuke. God
says, "As many as I love, I rebuke and
chasen or correct." The problem with the
church in the last days is is not
willing to correct the sins that are
among its members. And therefore, it is
puffed up. It's really hard for us to do
that sometimes. But as Paul says here,
that is the best thing we can do to save
people who are walking in the flesh so
their spirit can have eternal life.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, thank you all
panelists and thank you for joining us.
Well, I'm going to leave you with this
fun scripture song. is from 3R John
chapter 1 verse 2. Beloved, I pray that
you may prosper in all things and be in
health just as your soul prospers. 3R
John 1:2. [music]
God bless.
[music]
>> [music]